Hi everyone. Howdy. It is spring. It is. It is spring time. It's spring time and you guys, before we head out on spring break with our families, we wanted to pop in and say hi. That's right. We are going to give a re-listen to Chair Model this week because coming up in a few weeks, we're going to be breaking down Scott's Tots, which is considered the cringiest episode of the office. But another episode that was on that cringe list is Chair Model. Yeah. And we thought maybe to prep for the cringe factor of Scott's Tots, we should take a moment and re-listen to Chair Model. You know, that's the episode where Michael falls immediately and deeply in love with a woman sitting in a chair in a magazine.
He's in a catalog. Yeah. But before we do that, you guys, there was a deleted scene that I didn't share when we originally broke this episode down. And you know, it really shows you where Michael is at in his quest for true love. He's asking his co-workers to set him up. Here is his criteria. Bami. I don't have anybody. You don't have one single girlfriend? I'm not looking for a perfect 10 here. Just somebody to hang out with just fun, healthy young woman. Sorry. A kindergarten teacher who was great with kids, maybe an ex-model. And now she wants to do something with her brain. No,
I don't. How about a professional volleyball player who models on the side? Just a fun... Look, here, it doesn't have to be a model. I'm not... Don't rule out model. But just in terms of models, there are like 20 different categories. There's face models, hand models, body models. Pretty much just a model. Yeah. That's his criteria. Well, you know, I think maybe he has fallen in love with a chair model. And so he's real stuck on the model part. Real stuck. My favorite part of that was when he said, I mean, it doesn't have to be a model, but don't rule out a model. Don't take that as permission to not consider models. Right.
Oh, well, buckle in because there is more cringe in store for you. Here is chair model. And next week, we will be back with an all new episode shareholder meeting. That's right. You guys have a great week. We'll see you after spring break. I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on the office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the ultimate office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of the office and give exclusive behind the scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're the office ladies. Hi, everybody. Hello from our closet. Still here. Still in our closet. Still surrounded
by Josh's many, many hats. So many baseball hats. So many. Does he have a favorite? Can we get him on the pod to ask him to give us a breakdown of these hats? Are they significant emotionally in some way? Do they represent a team he loves? I mean, no, I think Josh is all about the fit and it looks like he loves the Patagonia kind of trucker looking hat. It does with the adjustable band thing, the little plastic snappies. Uh huh. Josh, I hope you are excited that we shared. Listen, there's other things in the closet right over my shoulder. I notice all the time that there's the, um, what's the stuff they spray in their shoes, Jenna? The breeze? No. All dudes do this. They spray that stuff in their shoes.
Odor eaters? Yes. Yes. Anyway, oh, now Josh, you're really happy. I've shared with everyone that you spray your shoes. Well, because we need to talk about this longer, I am really curious about the very bright red pair of shoes over your shoulder in the shoe cubby. Shoes are those. Oh, those are my red converse. Okay, so here's the thing. Yes, this is Josh's closet, but I occupy most of the shoe space. I have lots of shoes. You have overflow that goes into his closet. Yeah, he's real happy about it. Well, guys, it's what you're here for, a breakdown of Angela's closet. Next week, we'll do my closet. But this week, we are talking about chair model. It's so good. Season four, episode 14, written by BJ Novak,
directed by Jeffrey Blitz. With a duo like that, you know, it's going to be good. I love the simple idea that Michael has a thing for the model in a chair catalog. I just love how simple and perfect that is. Yes. Let me give you a summary. Do it. Michael is unable to pick a new chair for his office after he becomes infatuated with a woman modeling office chairs in a catalog. He decides he's ready to rejoin the dating pool. He's inspired by his love of the chair model. Meanwhile, the Dunder Mifflin parking spaces are being used by a construction crew doing work for WB Jones. And the staff of Dunder Mifflin has to park in a satellite lot. Kevin and Andy joined forces to confront the other bosses
of the Scranton Business Park to reclaim their places in the main lot. Simple storylines. Absolute perfection. Also, absolutely true. Yeah. You know, I had to park in a satellite lot when I had my admin job. If you were an executive, you could park in the parking lot of the building, this high rise in downtown Los Angeles. Yeah. I did not get a parking space. I had to park in a satellite lot that was about a half a mile away, and it wasn't a big deal, except for on days that it rained. Well, here's the thing. You know where you rank in a company by where you park. Oh, yeah. Well, Michael has a spot right up front. He's not concerned. Well, later he's going to try to imagine what it would be like if he didn't
have that spot. But it takes two employees angrily confronting him for him to get there. What are our fast facts, Jenna? Fast fact number one, the original title of this episode was Michael Dating. But they realized that they would have to release the name of the episode before dinner party had aired. Oh, and they didn't want that. They didn't want to ruin the surprise about Jan and Michael's breakup, right? Yes. So they changed the name of the episode to parking. But then they felt, well, while it's a big part of the episode, it's not the main storyline of the episode. So they eventually settled on chair model, which I personally love. I mean, when you see that, aren't you intrigued? I'm so intrigued.
What is this episode going to be about? Chair model. I'm more intrigued than parking. I'll say that they picked the right one. All right. Fast fact number two, I think we need to do a little breakdown of the Scranton Business Park five families. I mean, it's like good fellas. It is. All right. Here are the bosses of the five families, Michael Scott, of course, Bob Vance, Vance refrigeration. Then there is WB Jones from WB Jones Heating and Air. He was played by Barry Sigismondi, Bill Cress of Cress Tool and Die, who was played by Terrence Beaser. And finally, Paul Faust of Disaster Kits Limited, who was played by Paul Faust. This is an amazing story. And it all starts when an actual man named Paul Faust came to
visit the set of the office. Yes. So I have known Paul Faust for years. We used to be related by marriage. And I reached out to him and he is just such a hoot. And he sent in all of these fantastic audio clips about his day on set. They are amazing. And in this first one, he explains exactly how he got the role on the show. Sam, you got to play this clip. Hey, office ladies and office fans. This is Paul Faust, a cool guy, Paul. Want to tell you how I got a part of the show. So I was out in LA on business and decided to visit the set because my cousins are part of the office. And when I was out there, I met the writers and I kind of told them one of my companies and what I did, which was
a company that sells Disaster Kits. And Greg had said, this is my cousin. He's a little nuts. Tell him what you do. I told him about the company. And when I walked out of the room, unbeknownst to me, BJ Novak said, that guy's got to be a character on the show. So he wrote a part based on me. And the day before they shot the scene, they hadn't found an actor to play the part. So I got a call asking me if I wanted to audition to play the part. And long story short, I got the part, got to fly out and be part of the awesome show and play myself. So that's how I got to be on the, on the show. It's really a story only can happen in Hollywood. I mean, that's bonkers. I know he's literally playing himself.
But what's bonkers to me about it was that they did hold auditions. They held auditions for this role. And the night before, they just had not found someone who could play Paul Faust. So they're like, how about Paul Faust? Paul really sells Disaster Kits. That's real. That is his company. Oh yeah. And Angela, he talked about that in this next clip. I think one of the most unique things about me being in the office was that I actually played myself. When I went out to LA and I was listening and I went to the set, I talked about one of the businesses I run, which is a company called 1-800-PREPARE, 1-800-PREPARE.com, where we actually sell Disaster Kits and prepare this kits. So I talked about it and that's
what DJ had picked up on. And so he wrote a part called about Cool Guy Paul, the owner of Disaster Kits Limited. And yes, I still own that company. We still sell Disaster Kits. So I think I wanted a few people who played himself on TV with his real name in a real business that he runs, which was kind of cool. So we asked Paul, how did he prepare to have these scenes? He's not an actor. He's not used to learning lines or where to sit, how to navigate a set and all that kind of stuff. And here's what he had to say. So I got this part, let's say on a Thursday, and we were shooting Friday morning. So I
had about a good 10 hours to learn my five or six lines. So I'm studying, studying on the plane. I'm reading them. I didn't sleep. I studied them. So we go there and this whole experience happens and you're nervous and there's a lot of people around. And I had 10 hours to learn a bunch of lines. So I was able to do it. And we knocked it out and I got it done and I was like, great, I finished. And then all of a sudden somebody came in and they threw these new scripts down. They said, okay, here's the altered ending. Let's take a five minute break, learn our lines and come back to you. And I'm like, wait, wait, what a minute? Five minutes, what? I had 10 hours to learn my lines. Five minutes, I'm
not learning new lines. So I raced out the hallway, had to study, learn all the lines, learn when I came in and whatever, a lot of doing it, knocking it out, getting it done right. And again, life experience with amazing people who were just so supportive and I was glad that I was able to be a tiny part of this amazing family. Well, Angela, I found an interview with Paul and he said that he landed in LA at 1.30 in the morning. The airline lost his luggage. So he had no luggage. He got to his hotel and went to sleep about 3.15 in the morning and he had to be up at 5.00 a.m. for work. So after all of that, I'm kind of amazed. I would have been loopy. I would have been
able to learn new lines. No. And I think of Paul just like he's had no sleep. He's probably in the same underwear because they lost his bag. And now he's like, he thought he reached the finish line and then they hand him this whole new task. Well, Paul sent a few more clips about his experience just being on set. They're so delightful. We're going to sprinkle those in throughout the episode. All right. Fast fact number three, Angela. I'm titling this. Am I the inspiration for this episode? I'm sorry. What? Were you a cheer model? No. But in season one of the show, I wanted a new chair at reception and I had to lobby for it. So I'm sure I'm not
the inspiration for this episode. But in season one, they gave me a chair at reception without arms. It was an armless chair. And I really, really wanted a chair with arms. And so I attempted to try to sort of move the chairs or find a chair maybe that hadn't been claimed or used. It wasn't working. And big shout out to our set dresser, Steve Rothstein, because he is one of the guys who headed up the team that picked out all our furniture on the office. And he got me a chair with arms. Oh, lady. And I was so excited. Well, I have a chair story for you. I've been holding on to this. I'm going to go ahead and tell you now the chair I'm sitting in right now. Ready? I'm going to pan down. Do you see this chair?
I do. It's a blue chair with mesh. Do you recognize it? I don't recognize it, but it has no arms. Phil Shea gave me this chair. It was a leftover chair from work bus. Oh my gosh, you've been sitting in a work bus chair this whole time for a year in my closet. I have been sitting in my work bus chair and I was going to save it for work bus, but we're having all this chair talk. I couldn't hold it in anymore. Well, I just have to say this is why our show is so great because getting a chair is a very relatable big deal moment when you are in an office job or any job, your chair, you sit in it all day and they created this amazing, wonderful storyline out of it. Yes. And thank you Phil Shea because
I had gotten a desk, you know, I had in the corner of my guest room, a little desk where I would sit and do work and I didn't have a proper desk chair. I was using one of the kitchen chairs and I was sort of talking about it on set and Phil Shea was like, Angie, I have some extra chairs from work bus. Do you want one? I was like, yes. This is making me happy. I know. We all have a chair story. And I have been sitting in it for a year with you and haven't told you because I was going to try to work it in a work bus. But there you go. Let's take a break and when we get back, we'll get into it. All right. We are back. We open on a gym and Pam talking head. They are standing outside of the Dunder
Mifflin office and they are explaining that due to some renovations in the building, all of their parking spots are being taken up and they have to park in a satellite lot and walk to work. They're being really positive about it though. Yeah. They saw a junkyard dog eating, you know, some of a chicken. Yeah. Eating the bones of a rotisserie chicken, Angela, which was based on a real story. Yeah, it was. There was a junkyard next to our real office building and there was a junkyard dog who they would throw like old rotisserie chicken bones to. We've talked about this junkyard in the dog. We got very invested in this dog's life that lived over there. We did. And it made it into an episode. So then we
have Oscar and Andy, who are less positive. And then there's Kevin, who is just downright angry. Kevin is going to have a breakdown over this satellite parking lot. Yeah. Well, Andy says he's so bummed because he lost a penny out of his penny loafers. Yeah. Jenna, I don't understand penny loafers. So I looked him up. Oh, you could have asked me, I wore penny loafers all through high school as part of my school uniform. Okay. Well, why did you put a penny in your penny loafer? I don't know because there was a slot there for it. Okay. Well, I'll tell you, I'll tell you why. Oh, well, you have put me in my place. I clearly don't know about penny loafers. You told me I could have asked you. Well, you're
not answering my question. Why a penny in your loafers? So according to the internet, back in the 1930s, the pay phone in the phone booth cost two cents. The new loafer design allowed just enough space for a penny in each shoe, equaling the cost of an emergency phone call. Thus the penny and the loafer were united. But only men could make emergency phone calls. If you were a woman, so sorry, you don't even get a pocket to put your pennies in. Good luck, lady. You're just going to die on the street. But for the men, we have pockets, you can hide money in your shoes. Where else can we make life easy for you gentlemen? That took a turn, but point taken. So now the episode starts and Jenna, it would have started with
a deleted scene with Michael checking out of the Shrewt Farms. What? Yeah. Oh, because he's been staying with Dwight? Yes. So there was an alternate beginning where Michael is leaving the farm and he's like, it's moving day. You know, I've been here about a month. I let Jan have the condo and I'm moving out of Shrewt Farms. And as he's leaving Dwight goes hold up and hands him a bill. And Michael's like, wait, you were charging me this whole time? And Dwight was like, yeah. And then they have this funny back and forth about it. Oh my gosh, my mind is blown by the backstory that Michael lived with Dwight for a month. And it does sort of show why maybe now he's looking at the chair model like he is because
he's a month past his breakup. And I don't know, maybe he's ready for something new. Yeah. Oh, can we see this deleted scene somewhere? Yes, it's on the DVDs. Amazing. So the scene they went with is this one in his office. He's looking through the catalog and really just gazing at this lady in this chair. Well, we had some fan mail about it. Carly D, Jenna A, Mariah K, and Charlotte S all wrote in to ask who played the chair model in the picture. The chair model was played by April Eden. She would go on to play Trish, aka Miss Pawnee in two episodes of Parks and Recreation. Well, I have a little background catch at a minute and nine seconds. There's a wonderful shot of the chair model, but the magazine is sitting
on top of some message slips. Oh, and I zoomed in on the message slip. The message that was written down said Andrea Ufer or Uter, guys. I don't know. I couldn't make it out from Dunder Lewisville called and asked Michael to please call as soon as he returns. And the number was 307-555-4438. So I called it. Well, that's a fake number. Well, yeah, it rang fast busy, but I wasn't sure. So I called it. No, you know that thing where in movies, they always start phone numbers with 555 because nobody has that as a prefix. Jenna, I know that, but we've had a phone number and it ended up being a sex hotline. So I decided to do my due diligence. It is a phony baloney number, but the area code 307 is a Wyoming area code,
but there is no Lewisville in Wyoming. There you have it. Boom. Everything you needed to know about this message slip next to the catalog. Angela, I admire you. I do. I really love that detail. Pam just needs Michael to pick a chair so that she can get his chair. But he is now obsessed with the chair model and Pam is very sad. But then Michael has a talking head where he says he really likes being single because he can start off each day with a sense of possibility. And this was my favorite part when this talking head takes a turn. He says, and each day becomes more desperate, and desperate situations yield the quickest results, which is kind of true. It is true. There was an alt talking head here that was pretty amazing. Jenna, you know the
nursery rhyme where it's like Pam and Jim sitting in a tree, K-I-S-S-I-N-G, you know that one? Yes. So he has sort of used this nursery rhyme as a template for how to find your perfect match. And Sam, can you play it? Love, marriage, baby carriage. Those have been my goals ever since I heard that song. Jan and I had love. We did not have marriage. We did have a baby carriage, which I got her for bringing groceries home after she got a DUI. Oh my God. It's just so messed up. And I have to say, Jenna, in this scene with you when he says, remember after my dinner party when I said that I was swearing off women? The way you said, I definitely remember your dinner party was so good. You just crushed it. I love doing that scene
with Steve. I remembered when I was watching it, how much we were laughing. It was just so fun. That was a good memory. It's a very subtle reminder to the audience what just came before this. Yeah. Okay. Well, now, Jenna, we have a creed talking head that is phenomenal. It is phenomenal. He says, when Pam gets Michael's old chair, he gets Pam's old chair, which will bring him to two chairs, only one more to go. Why does he need so many chairs? You're not the only person who's wondering. We got a lot of mail about it. So I texted Creed. Oh no. And he had a lot of answers for why he needed three chairs, and I'm going to share them all. Wait, wait, is this sort of like Creed the actor giving Creed
the character backstory? Yes. Oh, I love it. All right. Option number one, he was growing weed in the ceiling. It was the same place where Angela threw her cat. Now he had access through a crawl space outside, but he needed to get in there at night by his desk. So after finally getting his three chairs and climbing into the ceiling, they collapsed one night, and he was stranded in the ceiling. He wants you to know that's the whole thing that could have happened. Creed, what the hell are you talking about? You're going to stack three office chairs? I think all three of them had wheels. Yeah. Well, here's option number two. He said Creed stole many things from the office, and he needed the extra chairs for a set because he was selling it to a competitive paper company.
That, I believe. Yes. I believe Creed had many side hustles. Well, here's his final answer. After perfecting his cartwheel, he wanted to use the three chairs as part of an obstacle course to really challenge himself. Well, that could have been very true. Oh, Creed, you're so fun. Thank you for humoring us time and time again. Well, Michael tells everyone in the bullpen, get out your catalogs, open them to page 85, and take a look at the woman in the catalog. Yeah. Use that as a template for who you're going to set me up with. Jenna, this was an announcement. He came out of his office to address his employees. Could you imagine working with a boss that made a huge announcement about how you should go about setting him up? No. Later, he says if you don't provide
him a name by the end of the hour, you're going to be fired. We'll get there, but it's crazy. So now here's what I noticed. We all do get out these catalogs, and we start opening up to page 85. And I remember these catalogs, Angela. Do you remember them? Yes. So we got mail about this, too. Mariah, Charlotte, and Christina all wanted to know, did the props department have to make an entire magazine just for these scenes with the catalog? No. So what they did was they had like an actual, I don't remember what it was, Angela. Do you, I think it was staples or office depot or something? And they glued a new cover on it. Yes. So it was like a Dunder Mifflin cover. Yeah. And then on the inside, on page 85, they glued this two pages so that when we opened it up,
yeah, we could show those two pages. But the rest of it was an actual office catalog. That's right. And they just had to print basically the cover and then the two insert pages that we would all turn to. Right. Jenna, you might notice there's not a lot of reaction shots of me in this because my belly was so big. I'm peak preggers here. That is why I'm not anyone that walked in, you know, like from the satellite parking lot. So Jenna, I don't know if you remember, but this week on our set, Chris Hastings, our NBC set photographer was there and he took a picture of me at my desk. I'm completely out of character and I'm pointing at my belly. Look, Jenna, here it is. Oh my God, you're huge. I know. Anyway, I'll put that in stories. But yeah, it was getting
really hard to hide my belly. Well, there were enough shots of you, Angela. And I noticed that they were all very close up. They're like shoulders and up. But it's enough for me to notice that you were wearing a blouse with tiny keys on it, little like skeleton keys. What was it? Lady, look at this picture. It's not a blouse. It's a freaking dress. It was a whole dress of it. It was a turtleneck dress. I mean, it looked like a Moo Moo. It was very comfortable. But we were starting to struggle with what could fit me over my belly and look like business attire of someone who was not pregnant. Yeah. I have a question for you. What is it? At three minutes, 35 seconds, you'll notice that Kevin and Michael are sitting on the sofa by front reception. Michael's wanting
Kevin to set him up. He's asking him about Stacy. Do you know why they're sitting on the sofa and why Michael isn't in accounting talking to Kevin? Well, I know that Kevin's feet are in a foot bath. Is that why, though? Yes, Jenna. There's a whole deleted scene where you're trying to answer the phone. But Kevin's foot bath, it's so loud. It sounds like a ginormous hot tub, but it's a little foot bath. So for the majority of this episode, Kevin is sitting there next to front reception. Yes. He is soaking his feet in his foot bath that he bought himself for the Christmas party episode, that very first episode. And it's such a wonderful callback. But since they cut that scene at reception, you can't even really see it. I tried to even find a time code where you could
see the foot bath and you can't. You can't. You can see just like Kevin's pants are hiked up. But you're like, why are they hiked up? Yeah. Why am I seeing Kevin's bare ankles? But it's because they're resting in a foot bath and that's in the deleted scenes. Well, now Michael's going to walk around the office. He's going to try to make pleas to various people in the office to see if they have any single friends that they can set him up with, which leads to a very funny runner with Phyllis about her friend Sandy. Phyllis is so good in this scene. So good. And the way Steve fires off his questions about Sandy. I mean, Phyllis says, look, she's gorgeous with a feisty personality. And Michael's like,
so wait, Jolly or Sassy? Right. And Phyllis is like, no. And he's like, well, what does she do for a living? And Phyllis is like, she's a professional softball player. Michael's like, catch her or infield. And she's like, I don't know. And then he asks her if she could fit in a rowboat in a standard size rowboat. And Phyllis gets so angry with him. She's like, fine, no, Michael. No, she can't fit in a rowboat. It's really amazing writing. Michael really loses it now, Angela. And he gives this impassioned speech where he says he wants to play ball with his kids before he's too old. But first, he needs to get laid. And that means he needs to be in love. Oh, that kind of made me love Michael for saying that. He just wants the picket fence and the kids
and the two car garage. And he just, Michael is one of these people and I and anyone out there that's had children, you know how you have one of your kids who just wants a family? Yes. And Michael was that kid since he was a little boy. All he wanted was a family. I mean, if you and not to be a downer, but I don't think Michael had a great family experience as a child and he's still longing for it as an adult. Of course. That's like part of his whole driving force. Yeah. Is to find family, whether it be at work or with a partner, he wants family. Yes. Well, this is now Angela, where Michael says, everybody, I want you to give me the name of someone that he can go on a date with within the hour or they're fired. And Dwight is going to hand out index cards that he's already
written prompts for. Did you see that? Yeah, he's ready. He's ready. Well, listen, let's take a break. And when we come back, we will find out how this goes. Guess what? Not well, should maybe, but short. That's right. Well, we're back. We're in Michael's office. Andy and Kevin are really making a passionate plea to Michael to please do something about these parking spots that the construction guys are blocking. Michael says, you know what? He's gotten assigned parking spots. So not really affecting him. And there is a couplet of dialogue, Jenna, that just cracked me up seven minutes, four seconds. Michael says, wish I could, but I can't. Well, can but won't should maybe short. And Kevin's like, Michael, please. And then Michael says, what part of short don't you understand,
Kevin? What part of short don't you understand? They're on their own. He's not going to help them. No. But he does give them permission to fix the problem themselves. Yeah. Right. Mm hmm. He thinks this will be a good thing for them to figure this out. Right. An exercise. Meanwhile, in the break room, I don't even know what title to give this. Everyone is sitting trying to come up with a name to put on their card for Michael. We had a fan question from Stephanie, Emily, Laura and Ann, when giving Michael names of single women, he should ask out Jim writes down Pam's mom. I know. Right. Was this an intentional foreshadowing or just a coincidence? Well, guys, spoiler alert. In future seasons, Michael is going to date Pam's mom. It was a very controversial
storyline. We'll get to it. I think this was the first time the writers had ever even thought of this idea. And it was just a funny joke in the moment. But I have to believe that it stayed in their brains. It planted a seed. Well, there's a deleted scene between Michael and Kelly, where Michael's like, Kelly, who are you going to set me up with? And she's like, well, I have a friend who's 23. And he's like, yeah. And she's like, Oh, you know, I actually have the perfect group to set you up with my friend's parents who've gotten divorced. And Michael's like, and he walks off disgusted. So there is sort of this running joke in this episode that didn't fully make it in that like, Kelly is going to set Michael up with this whole older group of
故事情节。我们等下会聊到。我想这还是编剧们第一次萌生这个想法。当时也只是一个挺好玩的笑话。但我得相信，这个梗留在他们的脑海里了。它埋下了一颗种子。嗯，迈克尔和凯莉之间有一段被删掉的场景，迈克尔说，凯莉，你要把我介绍给谁？她说，嗯，我有个朋友23岁。他说，耶。她说，哦，你知道，其实我有一个完美的人选想介绍给你——我朋友那对离婚的父母。迈克尔听了，一脸厌恶地走开了。所以这一集中其实有一个贯穿始终的小笑话，但并没有完全呈现出来，就是凯莉要给迈克尔介绍一整帮年纪比较大的
people. Right. The divorcee. I guess I'll say the writers at this time didn't know yet that they were going to write that storyline. But I think this was the beginning of something. It's the group mind lady. There it is in action. I love that Michael calls Wendy. It's so funny. Do you know who the voice of Wendy was? We got a lot of mail about it. And I wrote to Kent Zabornak. And he did not remember who we cast. But one of the finalists for the role was Lindsay Broad, who ends up playing an arc on the show. Yeah. Now, I don't think she got the role. I really listened to the voice and I think it was someone else. So I don't have the answer. But I thought it was very interesting that Lindsay had auditioned for just this voice role. Right.
人。没错。离婚男女。我想说的是，这时候的编剧们还不知道他们要写那条故事线。但我觉得这是某个事情的开始。这就是集体智慧女士。它正在发挥作用。我喜欢迈克尔打电话给温迪。太搞笑了。你知道温迪的声音是谁配的吗？我们收到了很多关于这事的邮件。我写信问了肯特·扎博尔纳克。他不记得我们选了谁。不过这个角色的最终候选人之一是林赛·布罗德，她后来在剧中演了一条故事线。对。现在，我觉得她没拿到这个角色。我仔细听了听那个声音，觉得是别人。所以我没有答案。但我发现林赛竟然为这样一个纯配音角色试镜，非常有意思。没错。
Well, you know, who's on the case? Who's always on the case? Dwight. Dwight, he's on the case. He's going to find Michael, the chair model. Yeah. And he says, I will find her and I will bring her to you. And as God is my witness, she shall bear your fruit. This is such good writing, in my opinion, that we set up that Dwight is going to go on this quest. And the quest literally lasts one scene. Like, I think the expectation in writing is that we're now going to watch Dwight go on a search for the chair model. But then he sums it all up in one talking head. Yeah, he basically only had to make two phone calls. So the furniture company put him in touch with the advertising agency, who put him in touch with the photographer, who put him in touch with the
好了，你知道谁在查这个案子吗？谁一直在查这个案子？德怀特。德怀特，他在查这个案子。他要帮迈克尔找到那个椅子模特。是的。他说，我会找到她，我会把她带到你面前。我以上帝向我起诉，她必为你开花结果。依我看，这写得太妙了，我们铺垫了德怀特要开启这段寻人之旅。而这段寻人之旅实际上只持续了一场戏。就像，我想大家在剧本上的预期是，我们接下来会看德怀特去找椅子模特。但接着他用一个直视镜头的访谈就全概括了。对，他基本上只打了两个电话。所以家具公司把他引荐给了广告公司，广告公司把他引荐给了摄影师，摄影师把他引荐给了
modeling agency. And the modeling agency told him that she died in a car accident. Case closed. Case closed. Investigation over. And by the way, he's super proud of his investigation. And it's not really landing on him that this is horrible news. Michael takes the news really hard. He has to sit down in Dwight's chair. Yeah. And Jim says, Michael, you didn't even know her. Gasp. Even Pam shakes her head at Jim. Like Jim, not now. Michael's like, try not to be so hurtful, Jim. Dwight's like, how dare you. And one of my favorite lines of this whole episode is coming up. What is it? Pam says, okay, Michael, you know what? I might have someone for you. And Michael says, oh, really? What's her name? Burger King. Yeah, that made me laugh out loud too.
模特公司。模特公司告诉他她在车祸中丧生了。结案。结案。调查结束。顺便说一句，他为自己的调查感到无比自豪。而且他并没有真正意识到这是一个可怕的消息。迈克尔听到这个消息大受打击。他不得不坐在德怀特的椅子上。是的。吉姆说，迈克尔，你甚至都不认识她。天呐。连帕姆都对吉姆摇了摇头。就像吉姆，现在别这样。迈克尔说，别这么伤人，吉姆。德怀特说，你怎么敢这样。这整集里我最喜欢的台词之一马上就要来了。是什么？帕姆说，好吧，迈克尔，你知道吗？我可能有个合适的人选介绍给你。迈克尔说，哦，真的吗？她叫什么名字？汉堡王。对，这也把我逗得哈哈大笑。
Made me laugh so hard. Pam, for whatever reason, decides to give Michael the phone number of her landlady. Margaret. She says she's really nice. And I think you might get along. I mean, Michael's jazzed. He's excited. He starts brushing his teeth in the kitchen sink. Why can't he do that in the men's room? Well, don't worry, Angela. He's not going to spit it out. He swallows it. Did you notice that? Yes. So disgusting. Also, electric toothbrush. Also, remember when we were wondering in local ad, does he have a toothbrush in the office? He does. So now the five families are going to be assembled. Andy and Kevin are doing it. Kevin has a talking head where he breaks down the five families, how they rarely ever meet. Yeah. And they have this great footage of each
把我笑惨了。帕姆不管出于什么原因，决定把她女房东的电话号码给迈克尔。玛格丽特。她说她人真的很好。我想你们俩会合得来。我是说，迈克尔兴奋极了。他很激动。他开始在厨房水槽里刷牙。他为什么不能去男洗手间刷？好吧，别担心，安吉拉。他不会把牙膏吐出来的。他把它咽下去了。你注意到了吗？是的。太恶心了。还有，电动牙刷。还有，还记得我们在拍《本地广告》时纳闷过，他办公室里有牙刷吗？他真的有。所以现在“五大家族”要集合了。安迪和凯文在搞这个。凯文有一个直视镜头的访谈，他在里面梳理了这五大家族，以及他们平时是多么难得聚在一起。是的。他们还放了每个
member of the five families. It's pretty amazing. I have two little fun facts from this. Okay. So now when they show WB Jones, they kind of show a clip of what looks like a commercial that he's in, where he's selling his air conditioners, right? Right. There's a 1-800 number in that commercial on the screen. Did you call it? I didn't need to call it because it's the exact same number that was on the flyer in women's appreciation, which we know is a sex hotline. Why do we keep recycling this number? I think we must have bought this number because after this episode came out, they put an outgoing message for WB Jones. So if you called it, you got that message. Yeah, we must have owned it for a bit and we clearly don't own it anymore. We really don't.
五大家族成员的很棒的素材。这真的太棒了。我从这里找到两个有趣的小彩蛋。好的。所以现在当他们展示WB·琼斯时，他们差不多放了一段他参演的广告剪辑，他在广告里卖空调，对吧？没错。那个广告的屏幕上有一个1-800开头的电话号码。你打过吗？我不需要打，因为那跟《女性尊崇日》里传单上的号码完全一样，我们知道那是个色情热线。我们为什么一直在循环使用这个号码？我想我们肯定是买下了这个号码，因为这一集播出后，他们为WB·琼斯设置了一个留言信箱。所以如果你打过去，你就能听到那个留言。对，我们肯定曾拥有它一段时间，但我们现在显然不再拥有它了。真的没有了。
Well, the other fun fact I have about this little montage is that at 10 minutes 55 seconds, we see a photo of cool guy Paul sitting on a motorcycle and there's a very interesting story here. Sam, will you play this clip from Paul? Hey, so a quick story about that motorcycle picture because a lot of people ask me, is that your motorcycle? And no, it's actually, we were shooting the scenes and we were supposed to shoot somewhere on some guy's house in the back deck, overlooking the ocean, but it got late in the day and they didn't want to move the whole crew and the cameras and the lighting and they have all that stuff. So right behind the lot where they shoot all the scenes where the office is, is a residential neighborhood. So we went through
好吧，关于这段小蒙太奇，我所知道的另一个有趣彩蛋是，在10分55秒时，我们看到了一张酷哥保罗坐在摩托车上的照片，这里有一个非常有趣的故事。萨姆，你能放一下保罗这段音频吗？嘿，关于那张摩托车照片有个简短的故事，因为很多人问我，那是你的摩托车吗？其实不是，当时我们正在拍那些场景，本来应该在某个家伙家后院的露台上拍，背景能俯瞰大海，但天色已晚，他们不想把整个剧组、摄像机、灯光以及所有那些设备都搬来搬去。所以，就在办公室所有场景拍摄地的正后方，是一个住宅区。于是我们穿过
the fence and it was some guy's house and we just set up on the front lawn. I believe it was the motorcycle of one of the camera guys. He happens to ride motorcycles. So he brought his motorcycle around. I sat on it. We took a bunch of pictures and that just became the shot associated with cool guy Paul and it saved having to move everybody to another location and spend hours doing it. So people always ask me, is that your motorcycle? How did you get the motorcycle? But nope, it was just a quick shot of one of the crew members' motorcycles. Well, Jenna, I reached out to Kenneth Paul who did my makeup on the show because he rode a Harley, right? To set. Every day to work. And I sent him the picture and I said, Kenneth Paul, is this your motorcycle?
栅栏，那是个普通人的家，我们就直接在前草坪上布置了。我猜那是某个摄像师的摩托车。他刚好骑摩托车。所以他把摩托车骑了过来。我坐上去。我们拍了一堆照片，这就成了与酷哥保罗相关的镜头，省得把所有人搬到另一个地方去花上好几个小时。所以人们总是问我，那是你的摩托车吗？你是怎么弄到这辆摩托车的？但其实不是，那只是其中一个剧组人员摩托车的快照。好吧，詹娜，我联系了在剧里给我化妆的肯尼斯·保罗，因为他骑的是哈雷，对吧？去片场。每天骑车去上班。我把照片发给他，我说，肯尼斯·保罗，这是你的摩托车吗？
And he said, no, Angela, that's not a Harley. It's not mine. So we don't know whose motorcycle it was, but I think that was Tom Melby's yard. Oh, for sure. When I heard Paul's clip and he said we went to some guy's yard through a fence, Tom Melby was our, I guess, general maintenance guy on the show. He was always fixing things when we went on vacations. He was the person who watered the plants and he lived right behind the set in a house. I loved the idea that cool guy Paul was originally going to be filmed like in a big mansion with the ocean behind him. It definitely tracks, right? Yeah. But then they had to scramble and they're like, what else is cool? Ooh, a motorcycle. And I kind of love the motorcycle better actually. I do too. So Jenna,
他说，不，安吉拉，那不是哈雷。不是我的。所以我们不知道那是谁的摩托车，但我猜那是汤姆·梅尔比的院子。哦，绝对是的。当我听到保罗的音频，他说我们翻过栅栏去了某个家伙的院子里，汤姆·梅尔比是我们剧组的，我猜是总务后勤人员。我们去度假时他总是负责修理东西。他就是那个负责浇花的人，他就住在片场后面的一栋房子里。我很喜欢这个设想：酷哥保罗最初本打算在一个能看到大海的豪宅里拍摄。这绝对很符合人设，对吧？没错。但后来他们不得不临时调整，他们想，还有什么也很酷？哦，摩托车。而且其实我更喜欢摩托车。我也是。所以詹娜，
at 11 minutes 30 seconds, it is time for Michael to go on his date. He's at the coffee shop. He's a little early. So he's going to go ahead and get a cup of coffee. Oh, here's his order. Large hot chocolate with caramel and a shot of peppermint. He's going to pay for it with his did you notice bejeweled wallet? No. Yeah. What? It's really subtle. But if you freeze at 11 minutes, 26 seconds, Michael is paying for his coffee. Yeah. And his wallet has an outline of little bedazzled fuchsia gems. I am so curious why did Jan get bored and bedazzle everything in their whole condo one day? Perhaps I looked at it so closely. There's no name on it. It's just an outline. I need to see that. Fascinating. Well, he's looking around and he's trying to figure out where's
在11分30秒时，迈克尔该去约会了。他在咖啡馆。他去得有点早。所以他打算先去买杯咖啡。哦，这是他的点单。大杯热巧克力加焦糖和一泵薄荷糖浆。他掏出他的——你注意到那个镶钻钱包了吗？没有。对。什么？真的很低调。但如果你在11分26秒暂停，迈克尔正在为他的咖啡付钱。是的。而且他的钱包边缘有一圈镶嵌着的小小紫红色宝石。我太好奇了，是不是简有一天太无聊了，把他们整个公寓里的所有东西都镶上了水钻？也许吧。我仔细看了看。上面没有名字。只有一个轮廓。我得去看看。太迷人了。好吧，他环顾四周，试图弄清楚
his date. He's wearing a rose on his lapel, right? Because that's how you'll know it's him. Could you imagine if Michael was in The Bachelor, that reality show? So crazy. That would be so good. I was thinking the other day, what would I be like on The Bachelor? Oh, God, you wouldn't do it. You'd say, oh, right, all these women have to kiss the same guy, my FU patriarchy. You wouldn't do it. But then I was sort of daydreaming about me getting out of the limo in my joggers and a hoodie and just keeping it super real. I was like, dude, I'm getting out of the limo, how you're going to see me most of the time after we have two kids. And if you love me now, you're going to love me then. And I think we should start this way.
他的约会对象在哪。他翻领上戴着一朵玫瑰，对吧？因为那样你才能认出他。你能想象如果迈克尔去参加《单身汉》那个真人秀会怎么样吗？太疯狂了。那一定太棒了。我前几天还在想，如果我去参加《单身汉》会是什么样？哦，天哪，你才不会去呢。你会说，哦，对了，所有这些女人都得亲同一个男人，去他的重男轻女社会。你才不会去呢。但后来我开始白日做梦，梦见自己穿着慢跑裤和连帽衫从加长豪华轿车里走出来，超级真实。我想，老兄，我要从加长豪华轿车里走出来，这可是我们在生了两个孩子之后，你平时最常看到我的样子。如果你现在爱我，你到时候也会爱我。我觉得我们应该从这样开始。
That'd be my pitch. You literally said that with like a snarl in your lip. You're like, this is I did. It's badass. It's a badass way to start a date. If you're getting out of a limo on my first date, you've already lost me. It's so true. If you want to dial up the doucheery, show up in your limo. Well, Michael sees a woman. It's such a funny line. He says, I'm looking for a woman in blue jeans and a black top with brown hair. And he goes, there she is. And the camera swings to a blonde, a tall blonde wearing a skirt, like a floral skirt with a top, clearly not the description he was given. But he says, there she is. I give her a 10 for looks and a three for describing herself. Oh, he's so charmed. Okay, obviously, the woman in the dress is not his date, since she's
这就是我的开场白。你刚才说这话时，嘴唇甚至还带着一丝狞笑。你就像，这就是——我确实笑了。这很硬核。作为约会开场，这很硬核。如果你在我的第一次约会时坐着加长豪华轿车从车里出来，你已经失去我了。确实如此。如果你想把装腔作势拉满，那就坐着加长豪华轿车出现吧。好吧，迈克尔看到了一个女人。这台词太搞笑了。他说，我在找一个穿蓝色牛仔裤、黑色上衣、留着棕色头发的女人。然后他说，她在那儿。镜头转向了一个金发女郎，一个穿着裙子的身材高挑的金发女郎，穿着一条印花裙和一件上衣，明显跟他被告知的描述不符。但他却说，她在那儿。我给她的长相打10分，给她的自我描述打3分。哦，他太着迷了。好吧，很明显，穿裙子的那个女人不是他的约会对象，因为她
dressed nothing as described. But then Pam's landlady walks in Margaret wearing jeans and a black top and Michael gets one look at her. He's clearly disappointed. And he tries to get out of it. Oh, it's so cringy. And she's really cute. And like, nice. Like, what is wrong with Michael? Michael has such a bad picker. Yes. Well, Pam's landlady was played by Brooke Dillman. She is an improv comedy actress. She starred in this sketch comedy show called blue collar TV. And by the way, she has voiced several characters on Bob's burger. She's amazing. She's just got the chops. Brooke is hilarious. I have just known her through improv circles over the years. And she's so funny. And you know, I know her role as Margaret was supposed to be understated. And I
的穿着跟描述的完全不一样。但接着帕姆的女房东玛格丽特走了进来，穿着牛仔裤和黑色上衣，迈克尔看了一眼。他明显很失望。他试图想脱身。哦，太尴尬了。而且她真的很可爱。而且人也很好。迈克尔到底怎么回事？迈克尔的眼光怎么这么差。没错。好吧，帕姆的女房东由布鲁克·迪尔曼饰演。她是一名即兴喜剧演员。她曾主演过一档名为《蓝领电视》的小品喜剧秀。顺便说一句，她还为《开心汉堡店》里的几个角色配过音。她太棒了。她很有喜剧功底。布鲁克超级搞笑。这些年来，我一直通过即兴喜剧圈认识她。她真的很好笑。你知道的，我知道她饰演的玛格丽特本来应该表现得比较内敛，但我
just wish you guys could see the comedy chop she has. I know you see it in her timing of the scene and all of that. But she is really, really funny. You know, a lot of times it takes a great comedic performer to play restraint. Yeah, to have the patience to play the restraint. Yes. And to not try to overload the scene with their own bits. Yeah. And she does it perfectly. Incidentally, she graduated from the University of Missouri's theater program. Good old Mizzou. That was about 90 minutes away from the school that I went to in Kirksville, Missouri. I had to drive through Mizzou, Columbia, Missouri to get to Kirksville. You and Brooke, Chris Croson. Exactly. I know. We're both two gals from theater schools in Missouri who landed on the office. Go Mo.
真希望你们能看到她身上的喜剧功底。我知道你们能从她在这场戏里的节奏感以及所有这些中看出来。但她真的非常非常搞笑。你知道，很多时候，需要一个伟大的喜剧演员才能演好克制。是的，要有耐心去演绎克制。是的。而且不要试图用自己的小段子塞满整场戏。是的。她做得完美无瑕。顺便说一句，她毕业于密苏里大学戏剧系。老密苏里。那离我在密苏里州柯克斯维尔上学的学校大约只有90分钟的车程。我去柯克斯维尔的时候必须开车穿过密苏里州哥伦比亚市的密苏里大学。你和布鲁克，克里斯·克罗森。完全没错。我知道。我们都是来自密苏里州戏剧学校并最终参演《办公室》的女孩。密苏里加油。
Oh, the scene between Margaret and Michael is so cringy. Michael literally is like rubbing his forehead like he's in pain. He's like, so you get the rent checks every month. And she's like, yeah. I mean, it's like, I know he's like, and then what do you do with them? And she goes, are you really asking me what I do with the checks that people give me? And he's like, I'm just I'm trying to make conversation. Okay. Oh, Michael. And he just talks about like, he goes, well, this is who I was dating before you. And he shows the photo of Jan. And then he calls her by accident. It's just like layer of layer of cringy. And then he kind of starts opening up to Margaret about like how it's so hard to find someone. And he tells her, you know, thanks,
哦，玛格丽特和迈克尔之间的这场戏太尴尬了。迈克尔简直像在揉额头，好像痛苦得不得了。他就像，所以你每个月都收到房租支票咯。她说，对。我的意思是，就好像，我知道他接着说，然后你拿它们怎么办？她说，你真的在问我别人给我的支票我拿来怎么办吗？他说，我只是——我只是想找点话说。好吧。哦，迈克尔。他甚至开始聊起别的，他说，好吧，这是我跟你之前约会的人。然后他给对方看简的照片。接着他不小心叫错了她的名字。这简直是一层又一层的尴尬。然后他开始向玛格丽特倾诉，说找个人有多难，他告诉她，你知道，谢谢你，
this has been nice. It's like talking to the old lady on the bus. And Margaret's had it. She's like, you're rude. That was rude. Well, and then Michael says, well, now you've ruined it. Michael was such a jerk in this scene. Listen, if you had any sympathy for him after dinner party, it evaporated after this scene. Yeah, we were very good at taking you on quite the roller coaster as your feelings for Michael are concerned on this show. But at this scene, I was like, you deserve Jan, you deserve to sleep on the bench at the foot of the bed. You're being such a turd. Exactly. It's very complicated. Well, now we go into this wonderful scene where Andy and Kevin are going to meet with the heads of the five families, make their plea. They're in what looks
这挺愉快的。就像在公交车上跟老太太聊天一样。玛格丽特受够了。她说，你太粗鲁了。刚才那样很粗鲁。好吧，然后迈克尔说，好吧，现在你把它全搞砸了。迈克尔在这场戏里真像个混蛋。听着，如果你在《晚餐派对》之后对他还有一点同情心，看完这场戏后也烟消云散了。是的，当涉及到你在剧中对迈克尔的看法时，我们真的很擅长带你坐过山车。但在这一场戏里，我想说，你活该拥有简，你活该睡在床尾的长凳上。你简直是个讨厌鬼。一点没错。这非常复杂。好吧，现在我们进入了这场精彩的戏，安迪和凯文将与五大家族的老大们会面，进行他们的陈述。他们身处的地方看起来
like to be some kind of conference room at the Scranton Business Park. I wanted to point out at 14 minutes, 12 seconds, how nice the frickin TV is in this conference room. Yeah, it is a true big flat screen TV, not like Michael's tiny one. Nothing like our crazy old tube TV that we roll in on a cart for our conference room scenes. Yeah, it's like a fancy big flat screen TV. Yeah, imagine if Michael had seen it, he would have passed out. Well, we asked Paul about shooting this scene, and I loved what he had to say. Here it is. So being on set, it's sort of be careful what you wish for because I'm a huge fan of the show. I think they're super funny. And I remember the first time we're about to shoot, they say, okay, quiet on the set, cameras rolling. And I will never
像是斯克兰顿商务园的某种会议室。我想指出的是，在14分12秒时，这个会议室里的那台电视机简直太赞了。是的，这是一台真正的超大平板电视，不像迈克尔那台小小的电视。一点也不像我们为了会议室的戏推车推进来的那种破旧的显像管电视。是的，就像一台高档大平板电视。是的，想象一下，如果迈克尔看到它，他肯定会晕过去。好吧，我们问过保罗关于拍摄这场戏的感受，我超爱他的讲述。就是这样。所以身处片场，这有点像“小心你许下的愿望”，因为我是这部剧的超级粉丝。我觉得他们超级搞笑。我还记得我们准备拍摄的第一场戏，他们说，好了，片场安静，摄像机开拍。我永远不会
forget it. But Brian says, okay, nobody asked Paul and he looks at me. And, you know, he was messing around, but it was so funny. And then the entire time we shot the scene, I had my lines to say, but we shot it about 20, 30 times. And every single time, Brian and Ed said different things. And I happened to think they're super funny. And it was very hard to keep straight face. I never knew what was going to come out of their mouths. They were making face to me trying to get me to laugh. And I just sit there and be dead serious. I don't want to be the guy to mess up the scene. So working with people who were literally comic geniuses in their delivery and their timing and having to sit there and being the new guy on set and trying to keep a straight
忘记这件事。布赖恩说，好吧，没人问保罗，然后他看着我。而且，你知道，他是在开玩笑，但太搞笑了。然后我们在拍这场戏的整个过程中，我有我的台词要说，但我们拍了大概20、30遍。每一次，布赖恩和爱德都会说不同的话。而我刚好觉得他们超级搞笑。要保持扑克脸真的太难了。我永远不知道他们嘴里会冒出什么。他们在我面前做鬼脸，想逗我笑。但我只能坐在那里，表现得极其严肃。我可不想成为那个搞砸这场戏的人。所以跟那些在台词功底和节奏把握上简直是喜剧天才的人合作，还得坐在那里，作为片场的新人努力保持扑克脸
face and not to mess up was a challenge. But such a life, a life experience and just so funny to do when I'm so honored to be a part of a small little part of the office. I love that Brian and Ed were trying to mess with them. We would do this. We would know when someone was going to break and we would have a little fun. We would. It's true. Well, Paul mentioned to us, you know, what it was like to get lines at the last minute, but he also talks to us about what it was like just being on the set and the lingo that they used. So we're shooting the scene over and over again. You know, we want to get it right. And sometimes the lines don't work, but the facial expressions are great. So one of the guys comes in and says, when this happens, I forget the word of use,
并不把事情搞砸，真的是个挑战。但这也是一段人生经历，拍起来太逗了，我非常荣幸能成为《办公室》这小小一部分的一员。我喜欢布赖恩和爱德试图捉弄他的举动。我们以前也会这么做。我们会知道什么时候有人要笑场，然后我们会找点乐子。我们会这么做的。确实如此。好吧，保罗对我们提到，你知道，最后一分钟才拿到台词是什么感觉，但他也跟我们聊了聊身处片场以及他们使用的行话是什么体验。所以我们一遍又一遍地拍这场戏。你知道，我们想把它拍好。有时台词效果不好，但面部表情很棒。所以其中一个人走过来，说，当发生这种情况时，我忘了用的那个词，
I want you to do this. And then he walked out and I'm looking around like, I have no idea what that means. So the camera guy behind me, he's like, you don't know what that means. I'm like, no, I've never done this before. He goes, okay, I'll tap you on the shoulder when you should say your line. So I was literally sitting there and something was going on. And I felt the camera guy who was shooting over my shoulder tapping on the shoulder when to say my line. And it was just sort of indicative of the whole experience because everybody was so friendly and helpful and just wanted to get it done right. Except I think, Brian and Ed, who were just trying to make me laugh the whole time. Can I say, Angela, that when we got these audio clips from Paul, the thing that was
我要你这样做。然后他走了出去，我环顾四周心想，我完全不知道那是什么意思。于是我身后的摄影师说，你不知道那是什么意思吗？我说，不，我以前从没做过这个。他说，好吧，当你该说台词时，我会拍拍你的肩膀。所以我真的就坐在那里，现场正进行着什么。然后我感觉到正对着我肩膀拍摄的摄影师在我该说台词时拍了拍我的肩膀。这简直是整个剧组体验的写照，因为每个人都那么友好、乐于助人，只想把事情做好。除了布赖恩和爱德吧，我想他们俩一直在试图逗我笑。我能说吗，安吉拉，当我们收到保罗的这些音频剪辑时，最让我开心的是他作为一个非演员在片场的观察，因为这真的把我带回了我演艺生涯中所有那些你只能在边学边干的时刻。我在戏剧学校根本没学过这些东西。而且我甚至不知道还有没有其他学习的方法。你只能在当时当下把它们吸收进去。但他发来的这段音频是我的最爱。我也是。
so fun for me was his observations as a non-actor being on a set, because it really took me back to all of those moments in my career as an actor where you just are learning on the fly. I didn't learn any of this stuff in theater school. And I don't even know if there is any other way to learn it. You just kind of absorb it in the moment. But he sent in an audio clip that is my favorite. Me too. Because I struggled with this too. You and I have talked about this, but I don't think we've ever talked about it on the pod. So this is great. I love that he had the same observation. Okay, we'll play it and then we'll talk about it. So this was a new experience for me. I kind of was my first time being really on the set. And I'm sitting on my trailer going, what do I do now? So
因为我也为此挣扎过。你和我聊过这个，但我觉得我们从没在播客里聊过。所以这太棒了。我很高兴他也有同样的观察。好吧，我们放一下音频，然后我们再聊。所以这对我是崭新的体验。这差不多是我第一次真正身处片场。我坐在我的房车里心想，我现在该做什么？于是
I decided to get something to eat. I walk out and I'm like, where can I get some food? And they pointed me in the direction of where the breakfast was. And as I started walking, I heard someone in the headset go, cool guy, Paul's going to breakfast. And then I come back and I hear them go, cool guy, Paul's back in the trailer. And we're where I went. Someone's like, cool guy, Paul's in the bathroom, cool guy, Paul's in it. Like someone I didn't know where I was at all time. I thought it was really funny. They had to track me to make sure they knew where I was in case they needed me. So that was one super funny story from being on the set. Yeah, you guys, on film and television sets, there is a whole network of production assistants
我决定去吃点东西。我走出去心想，我在哪里能弄点吃的？他们指给我早餐所在的方位。当我开始走的时候，我听到对讲机里有人说，酷哥保罗去吃早餐了。然后我回来，我听到他们说，酷哥保罗回到房车里了。我们在我走过的地方。有人会说，酷哥保罗在洗手间，酷哥保罗在——就像有人无论何时都知道我在哪一样。我觉得这真的太搞笑了。他们必须追踪我，以确保他们在需要我时知道我在哪。所以这是在片场的一个超级搞笑的故事。是的，你们大家，在电影和电视片场，有一个由制作助理组成的庞大网络
that wear these walkie talkies and they have little earpieces, kind of like the secret service, you know, but not as fancy, but not as fancy. Like when they talk into them, you hear it echo. Well, their job is literally to keep track of all the actors at all times. And you can hear them tracking you all day as you walk by, as you walk by. And sometimes you hear it from the person directly behind you who's actually speaking about you. And then you hear it in stereo from the other person they're talking to as you walk past them. And I guess the theory behind it, Jenna, is that production needs to know where we are because if the scene is lit and ready, they need us on that soundstage ready to go. And they can't have an actor unaccounted for because then that holds
他们拿着这些对讲机，戴着小耳机，有点像特勤局，你知道，虽然没那么高级，但没那么高级。就像当他们对着对讲机说话时，你能听到回音。好吧，他们的工作实际上就是随时掌握所有演员的行踪。当你们走过时，一整天都能听到他们在追踪你，当你走过时。有时你会直接从你身后那个实际上正在谈论你的人那里听到。然后当你从另一个人身边走过时，你会从他们正在交谈的另一个人那里听到立体声的回音。我猜背后的原理是，詹娜，制作组需要知道我们在哪，因为如果场景打光完成并准备好了，他们需要我们在摄影棚里随时待命。他们不能出现一个找不到人的演员，因为那会耽误
everyone up and it costs money, right? Yeah. So when they're lighting a scene, they let you go back to your trailer, you might use the restroom, you might get a snack. In our case, maybe we pop over to the writer's building and we're hanging out. But once the scene is ready, they have no time to lose because a production day is very regimented. And if you run out of time, that means you probably have to cut something. And you don't want that, right? You don't want to have to cut content. Right. So yeah, all day long. But my favorite thing, Angela, is that they came up with a code for the bathroom. I guess maybe it's to be, I don't know, more discreet. But everyone knows what the code is. The code is 10, 1. Jenna is 10, 1. Everyone knows when you go to the bathroom on
所有人，而且要花钱，对吧？是的。所以当他们在为一个场景打光时，他们让你回房车，你可能会去洗手间，你可能会吃个点心。对我们来说，也许我们跑到编剧大楼去闲逛。但一旦场景准备就绪，他们就一秒钟也不能耽误，因为制作日的时间非常严苛。如果你时间用完了，那就意味着你可能得删掉某些内容。你不想那样，对吧？你可不想不得不删减内容。没错。所以，一整天都是这样。但我最喜欢的是，安吉拉，他们竟然想出了一个洗手间的代号。我猜可能是为了，我不知道，更低调一点？但每个人都知道这个代号是什么。这个代号是“10-1”，詹娜是“10-1”。每个人都知道当你在片场去洗手间时，每一个人，都会通过每一台对讲机广播。安吉拉“10-1”，詹娜“10-1”。我只想让你知道，如果你需要待一阵子，而且你要在里面待上一会儿，每次他们广播詹娜“10-1”时，我都会产生很大的焦虑，因为我想我最好快点，否则他们会以为我在大号。
a set, every single person, it goes through every walkie talkie. Angela, 10, 1, Jenna, 10, 1. And I just want you to know, what if you need to tend to, and you're going to be in there for a minute, every time they would announce Jenna is 10, 1, I would get a lot of anxiety because I would think I better make it fast or they're going to think I'm doing a poop. Right. What about when we both started pumping? And then you would hear in the walkie, Angela's pumping, Angela's going to pump. Yeah. All your business. All your business through a walkie talkie. It's crazy. And I get why they have to do it, but it is very surreal. And so that clip from Paul really, Jenna and I immediately called each other. We're like, Oh my gosh, he talked about the thingy with the tracking. The tracking.
那当我们俩开始背奶时呢？然后你就会在对讲机里听到，安吉拉在背奶，安吉拉要去背奶了。是的。你所有的隐私。你所有的隐私都通过对讲机广播出去。太疯狂了。我理解他们为什么必须这么做，但这真的很超现实。所以保罗的那段音频，詹娜和我立刻给彼此打了电话。我们就像，哦天哪，他聊了那个追踪的事。追踪。
They should warn you in film school that you're going to be tracked all day. They should warn you because it's very jarring at first. Yeah. Well, let's just say that this meeting of the five families goes very well. It also goes very quickly in about three sentences. WB Jones agrees. Fine. You can have your parking spaces back. It's a triumph. Listen, it looks like Kevin's about to cry and Bill Kress is not here for that. He can't handle a grown man crying about a parking spot. And so Paul Faust calls it. He's like, just give them their spots back. And it just wraps up so quickly. It does. And then Paul has a great line where he says this could have been an email. Which is like a meme. It also speaks to me. Yeah. I mean, Paul needs to get out and ride his motorcycle.
他们在电影学校里应该警告过你，你一整天都会被追踪。他们真该警告一下，因为一开始真的让人很不习惯。好吧，让我们直说吧，五大家族的这次会面非常顺利。进展也非常快，大约三句话就搞定了。WB·琼斯同意了。好吧。你们可以把停车位拿回去。这真是一场大胜。听着，凯文看起来快哭了，而比尔·克雷斯可不吃这一套。他可受不了一个成年人为一个停车位哭泣。所以保罗·费斯特拍板了。他说，就把车位还给他们吧。事情就这样迅速解决了。确实如此。然后保罗有句很棒的台词，他说这本可以发一封邮件。这简直就像个网络热梗。这也说出了我的心声。是的。我是说，保罗得出去骑他的摩托车了。
He's done. Kevin's talking head after this scene broke my heart. Brian did such a good job with it. He just says that after Stacy broke up with him, it was really a tough time. And well, it's just nice to win one. And he tears up. It was so sweet. Yeah. Guys, we didn't go to the character of Kevin very often for a heartfelt moment on the show. And it's a shame because Brian Baumgartner is a fantastic actor. Yeah. And you can see that in this talking head. Yeah. I was excited to get to see this performance from him. Great job, B. Oh no, Michael has come back from his date and he's very angry. He gives a big speech. Angela, here are the things that he's a man of. Intensity, cool youth and passionately. He's a man of passionately. He's a man of youth
他搞定收工了。这场戏之后凯文的访谈让我心碎。布赖恩演得太棒了。他只是说，在斯黛西跟他分手后，那段日子真的很难熬。而且，能赢一次感觉真好。他泪流满面。太感人了。是的，伙计们，我们在剧中其实很少通过凯文这个角色来展现走心的时刻。这真的很遗憾，因为布赖恩·鲍姆加特纳是一位极其出色的演员。是的，你从这个访谈中就能看出来。是的。我很高兴能看到他贡献这段表演。干得漂亮，B。哦不，迈克尔约会回来后非常生气。他发表了一大段演讲。安吉拉，以下是他所具备的特质：激情、冷酷的青春和热情地。他是一个充满热情地的人。他是一个充满青春和热情地的人。
and passionately. Well, at 15 minutes, 10 seconds, you might notice I'm writing on the top of my desk. I have several papers on this very little thin lip of the top of my desk. I had to do that for camera because when I was staging my writing on the actual desk, they couldn't see my face when Michael entered. I have to imagine that was a tough reach and very awkward because you're leaning over your desk to write on a tiny ledge. Well, I'll tell you something. Pam's desk was very narrow in general. I couldn't fit more than a keyboard on it in order to write on Pam's actual desk, which was made very thin, I think, for production. It was always awkward, always. Yeah, so I've perched up on that little ledge, which was also awkward.
好吧，在15分10秒时，你可能会注意到我在桌子边缘写字。我有好几张纸放在我这张桌子顶部非常窄的薄边缘上。我为了镜头不得不这么做，因为当我把写字动作安排在真正的桌子上时，迈克尔进来时他们就拍不到我的脸了。我得说那一定很难够到，而且非常别扭，因为你得俯身趴在桌子上在一处狭小的边缘写字。好吧，我告诉你一件事。帕姆的桌子总体来说非常窄。我桌面上除了放一个键盘外根本放不下别的，为了能在帕姆那张实际上被做得非常窄的桌子上写字，我想那是为了拍摄需要。一直都很别扭，总是这样。是的，所以我得高高地趴在那个小边沿上，这也同样很别扭。
In this scene, Jenna, it seems like Jim and Pam are just teasing each other. He's like, what were you thinking, setting Michael up with your landlord? Now you have to move out. That went horribly. They're joking and she's like, maybe I should move in with my boyfriend. Then Pam has a moment of vulnerability and you see it in your face, Jenna, where you're going to be an advocate for yourself. This is something you've been working on. She says, you know what? I'm only going to move in with my boyfriend if I'm engaged. Yeah, and Jim doesn't miss a beat. He's like, oh, it's coming. Of course. Then Pam just keeps joking along. Jenna, I was like, in the moment, I was positive that Jim was serious. Does Pam know? Does Pam know he's doing a bit? Does it hit her
在这场戏里，詹娜，感觉吉姆和帕姆只是在互相调侃。他说，你怎么想的，把迈克尔介绍给你的房东？现在你得搬出去了。那可太糟糕了。他们在开玩笑，而她说，也许我该搬去和男朋友一起住。接着帕姆露出了脆弱的一面，从你的脸上能看出来，詹娜，你准备为自己争取权益了。这是你一直在努力的方向。她说，你知道吗？只有当我订婚了，我才会和男朋友同居。是的，吉姆连眼皮都没眨一下。他说，哦，它要来了。当然。然后帕姆继续开着玩笑。詹娜，当时我想，我确信吉姆是认真的吗？帕姆知道吗？帕姆知道他在抛梗吗？她意识到他不是在开玩笑吗？我觉得这可能在我的角色背景故事里，差不多是他们考虑订婚或结婚这个想法的第一次真正浮现。这也是为什么当帕姆说“哦，在订婚之前我不会跟任何人同居”时，我选择稍微犹豫一下的原因，因为这种关于订婚的想法，我觉得他们之前好像还没怎么聊过。
that he's not? I think this maybe in my backstory was kind of one of the first times that this idea of them getting engaged or married has really come up. That was a reason why I chose to kind of hesitate as well when Pam says, oh, I'm not going to move in with anyone until I'm engaged is because this idea of being engaged, it's not something that I thought they had talked about a lot yet. No, and that's how it reads. As an audience, I loved it because this is how real life stuff comes up. Sometimes it just seeps in to like a mundane conversation and then you're like, oh crap, we're here now. Okay. Yes. And so I think Pam isn't totally sure what to do with this conversation. Was it a bit? Is he being serious? Now he has a talking head for the audience where he says,
对，这就是给人的感觉。作为观众，我超爱这个情节，因为这就是现实生活中事情发生的方式。有时它只是悄悄渗透进一段乏味的对话里，然后你就会想，哦糟糕，我们现在竟然聊到这了。好吧。是的。所以我觉得帕姆完全不知道该怎么接这个话。这是个玩笑吗？他是认真的吗？现在他面向观众做了一个直视镜头的访谈，他说，
oh, I'm not kidding. I got this a week after we started dating and he shows an engagement ring. And I'm sorry, does he carry it to work with him every day? I don't know. Does it live in his pocket? Is he too worried to leave it at his apartment? Like, he hasn't ready to go. We had a fan question from Abigail B who said, is the ring Jim shows the camera, the ring he proposes with later and the one that Pam wears for the rest of the show? I think it is. I think that it is. I remember Phil Shea coming up to me and presenting me with a tray of rings. And he and I had a very long conversation about what kind of ring would Jim buy Pam? Like Jim's going to hit it out of the park for Pam.
哦，我可不是在开玩笑。我们开始交往一周后我就买了这个，然后他展示了一枚订婚戒指。对不起，他是每天都把它随身带去上班吗？我不知道。它一直待在他口袋里吗？他是太担心而不敢把它留在公寓里吗？就像，他已经随时准备好了。我们收到了一位名叫阿比盖尔B的粉丝提问，她说，吉姆给镜头看的这枚戒指，是他后来求婚的那枚戒指，也是帕姆在剧集剩下的部分里一直戴的那枚吗？我想是的。我觉得就是那枚。我记得菲尔·谢伊走向我，拿出一个装满戒指的托盘。他和我就吉姆会给帕姆买什么样的戒指进行了一场非常漫长的对话？就像吉姆肯定要为帕姆选一枚绝不出错的戒指。
Remember, Pam was always a little disappointed in her ring from Roy. That was my backstory. The cluster? Yes. And so Phil was like, what would make Pam's heart sing? And I remember picking that ring. So yeah, I think it is that ring. Pretty bold move, Jim, to buy it the first week you guys started dating. Yeah. But I guess he knew he loved her for a long time. Yeah. Well guys, here's the scene that's in Michael's office that I love. It's shot a little differently. This was Jeff Blitz. You know, there's always so many of the same scenes in the same places because we only had one set and every once in a while a director would find a fun way to shoot. And Jeff Blitz had this idea for this scene between Michael and Dwight that he would just lower the camera a little
还记得吧，帕姆对罗伊送她的戒指一直有点失望。那是我的背景故事。那个碎钻拼接的戒指？是的。所以菲尔就问，什么能让帕姆芳心暗许？我记得我选的就是那枚戒指。所以是的，我觉得就是那枚戒指。真是个大胆的举动啊，吉姆，你们交往第一周就把它买下来了。是的。不过我猜他早就知道自己爱她很久了。好吧，伙计们，接下来是迈克尔办公室里的这场戏，我超级喜欢。它的拍摄手法有点不同。这是杰夫·布里茨拍的。你知道，由于我们只有一个片场，在相同地方拍摄的相同场景总是很多，偶尔导演会找到一种有趣的拍摄方式。而杰夫·布里茨对这场迈克尔和德怀特的戏有个想法，就是把摄像机再放低一点，
and shoot at an angle and slowly push in as Dwight convinces Michael that what he needs is closure. And when I watched the scene, there was a brief moment that I thought he meant with Jan. Same. He needs closure with Jan, but no, no, it's with the chair model. So they head to the cemetery of a woman he's never met. That's right. And they are going to launch into a tribute to her by singing a version of American Pie. Bye, bye, Mr. Model Lady. Oh my gosh. So you know, the writers actually had a hard time getting a song cleared for this shocker. The first song they were going to parody was Elton John's Candle in the Wind, but they could not get the rights because here's an interesting bit of trivia. He had given permission for the song to be parodied on 30 Rock and he
从一个角度拍摄，随着德怀特说服迈克尔他需要的是解脱，镜头慢慢推近。当我看到这场戏时，有一会儿我还以为他是指简。我也是。他需要从简那里得到解脱，但并没有，不，对象是那个椅子模特。所以他们前往一个他从未谋面的女人的墓地。没错。他们要在那里通过唱一首《美国派》的变奏版来向她致敬。再见，模特小姐。哦天哪。所以你知道，编剧们其实很难为这个冲击性的情节争取到一首歌的版权。他们原本打算恶搞的第一首歌是埃尔顿·约翰的《风中之烛》，但他们拿不到版权，因为这里有个有趣的冷知识。他曾允许这首歌在《我为喜剧狂》中被恶搞，但他
did not care for the results. So he said no more parodies of Candle in the Wind. No. Okay. They also wrote parodies of Legs by ZZ Top. She's got legs. How is that a song you sing at a grave site? She was a chair model and you really see her legs in the picture. Oh my gosh. Okay. And then also Ruby Tuesday by The Rolling Stones. Oh, I love Ruby Tuesday. But the song that got cleared was American Pie and I'm so glad it did because I really love them in the dark singing. Well, we can't wrap up this episode without this adorable scene. Jenna, I literally wrote adorable and highlighted it between Jim and Pam as they're walking to the satellite parking lot and the sun is setting. You guys both look like angels. You both look so flip and adorable. Well, I remember we had to
对结果很不满意。所以他说再也不准恶搞《风中之烛》了。不。好吧。他们还写了对ZZ Top乐队《美腿》的恶搞歌词。她有一双美腿。你怎么能在墓地唱这种歌？她是个椅子模特，你确实能在照片里看到她的腿。哦天哪。好吧。还有滚石乐队的《红宝石星期二》。哦，我超爱《红宝石星期二》。但最终获得版权的歌曲是《美国派》，我太高兴了，因为我真的很喜欢他们在黑暗中唱歌的画面。好吧，如果没有这场超级可爱的戏，我们就不能算完美收官。詹娜，我简直在笔记里写下了“可爱”两个字并加了高亮，这是吉姆和帕姆在走向卫星停车场、夕阳西下的时候。你们俩看起来都像天使。你们俩看起来都太萌、太可爱了。好吧，我记得我们不得不
wait in our trailer for that light. That's called the magic hour. Yeah. In the biz and there's this little 45 minutes when the sun is truly magical. Everybody take your photos at magic hour. It's when you look the best. That's right. If you're planning a wedding, plan for some like magic hour photos. Yeah. So we waited for that moment and we could only do a few takes because then we were going to lose the light. He drops to one knee. Well, I'll tell you, this moment was promote like crazy. Like crazy. I bet they blasted it out. Yeah. Well, you know, we talked about how season four was interrupted by the writer strike. The writers originally had this very, very big storyline for Jim and Pam that I think involved them moving in together if I'm correct. And
在房车里等待那种光线。那叫魔幻时刻。是的。在行话里，那是太阳真正神奇的小小45分钟。所有人都在魔幻时刻拍照。那是你看上去状态最好的时候。没错。如果你在筹备婚礼，一定要安排一些魔幻时刻的照片。是的。所以我们等待着那个时刻，而且我们只能拍几条，因为接下来光线就要消失了。他单膝跪地。好吧，我得说，这个时刻当时被宣传得铺天盖地。铺天盖地。我敢打赌他们到处狂发预告。是的。好吧，你知道的，我们聊过第四季是如何被编剧大罢工打断的。编剧们原本为吉姆和帕姆准备了一条非常非常宏大的故事线，如果我没记错的话，其中涉及他们搬到一起同居。而
instead, because we lost a bunch of episodes, they were like, you know what, we should skip that and they should just get engaged or we should just skip to the part where we're thinking they might get engaged any minute. And so that was where this part of the story came from. I like it. I like that Pam still had her own place. I like all of that storyline for her because you sort of feel like Pam lived with Roy for a long time. And then she finally carved out her own space in the world. And I really liked that choice. Well, your reaction when you realize that Jim is faking is so great. It's so cute. You're like, I hate you. And he's like, what? It's really cute. Yeah. I have some bad news. What? I mean, spoiler alert, Pam's going to need to go to art school. We're going to frustrate you.
相反，因为我们少拍了好几集，他们就想，你知道吗，我们应该跳过那个部分，他们应该直接订婚，或者我们应该直接跳到大家觉得他们随时可能订婚的阶段。所以这就是这段故事来源。我挺喜欢的。我喜欢帕姆仍然有她自己的住处。我喜欢她身上的所有这些故事线，因为你会觉得帕姆跟罗伊在一起住了很长时间。然后她终于在世界上开辟出了属于自己的空间。我真的很喜欢这个选择。好吧，当你意识到吉姆是在假求婚时，你的反应太棒了。太可爱了。你就像，我恨你。而他说，什么？真的太可爱了。是的。我有个坏消息。什么？我是说，剧透警告，帕姆接下来得去上艺术学校了。我们要让你们抓狂了。
I know this proposal is going to take a little while, but we're planning the seeds. They have to pull you guys apart to put you back together. It makes me crazy. I know. Well, guys, that is chair model. Next up is night out. I'm really enjoying season four, Angela. I have to say me too. So fun. And for all of you chair models out there, just know your work is not in vain. You might be inspiring others to find true love. And Paul, thank you so much for sitting in these audio clips and being so quick to respond when I texted you. You are just such a delight. And I adore you. And these made our day, Jenna. And you guys, 1-800-prepare-dot-com, get your preparedness safety and survival information there
我知道这个求婚还要等上一阵子，但我们正在播种。他们必须先把你们俩拉开，然后再把你们合到一起。这让我抓狂。我知道。好吧，伙计们，这就是《椅子模特》。接下来是《外出之夜》。安吉拉，我真的很享受第四季。我不得不说我也是。太好玩了。对于你们所有的椅子模特而言，只要知道你们的工作没有白费。你们可能会激励其他人去寻找真爱。还有保罗，非常感谢你发来这些音频剪辑，而且在我给你发短信时回复得这么快。你真的是个开心果。我太喜欢你了。这些让我们的这一天都变得美好了，詹娜。还有伙计们，1-800-prepare-dot-com，去那儿获取你的备灾安全和生存信息吧
and all the kits you might ever need. You know I'm on that. Oh, I know. I was like, oh, Paul, there's some good stuff on here. Christmas gift for me, earmark that. Survival and emergency kits and products, Jenna. We'll see you next week, everyone. See you next week. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Earwool, Jenna Fisher, and Angela Kinsey. Our show is executive produced by Cody Fisher. Our producer is Cassie Jerkin. Our sound engineer is Sam Kiefer. And our associate producer is Ainsley Bubicoe. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. For ad-free versions of Office Ladies, go to StitcherPremium.com. For a free one-month trial of Stitcher Premium, use code Office. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
还有你可能需要的各种急救包。你知道我最喜欢这个了。哦，我当然知道。当时我想，哦，保罗，这里面有好东西啊。留着当我的圣诞礼物吧。生存和应急急救包以及相关产品，詹娜。大家下周见。下周见。感谢收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》由 Earwool、詹娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金西共同制作。我们的执行制作人是科迪·费舍尔。我们的制作人是卡西·杰金。我们的音响工程师是萨姆·基弗。我们的助理制作人是艾恩斯利·布比科。我们的主题曲是克里·布拉顿的《Rubber Tree》。想要收听无广告版的《办公室女士》，请访问 StitcherPremium.com。注册 Stitcher Premium 可享一个月免费试用，使用优惠码 Office。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。